Whether they were burnt out after multiple seasons
or killed off to make room for another actor,
these sci-fi stars left their most
popular shows for all kinds of reasons.
As FBI agents Fox Mulder and Dana Scully,
played by David Duchovny and Gillian Anderson,
tackled mysterious cases involving supernatural
phenomena on "The X-Files." Mulder always assumes
a paranormal link, while Scully takes
a more skeptical approach. But after
Duchovny chose to leave the series at the
end of season seven, the show just wasn't
the same. In a statement released after the
news of his departure broke, Duchovny said,
"As much as I love the show, I think for
me this will be the end. I always thought
five years was enough. Seven
years is definitely enough."
Duchovny's contract was officially up at the
end of the seventh season — and rather than
renewing it, he de cided to leave. Another
factor also prompted him to say goodbye,
however. Duchovny was also stuck in a legal battle
with Fox over syndication revenue, as he felt
Fox was taking in greater profits from reruns
while reducing his own earnings from royalties.
"Sounds like a motive."
The original series continued on for two more
seasons, with Duchovny making only occasional
appearances. However, he did return to his
leading role in the tenth and eleventh seasons,
which aired in 2016 and 2018, well
after the initial run had wrapped up.
In the mid-2000s, there might not have been
any show hotter than "Lost," the polarizing
sci-fi survivalist thriller. While the
show saw plenty of characters come and
go over the course of its lengthy run,
none were as controversial as Mr. Eko,
the drug dealer and thug-turned-priest played
by Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje. Introduced at
the start of the second season, he was
killed off in that same year's finale.
Though many fans have argued about how little
of "Lost" was well-planned, there seems to
be other reasons for Akinnuoye-Agbaje's
departure, as he unexpectedly asked out of
the series before the season had wrapped
up. According to producer Carlton Cuse,
Akinnuoye-Agbaje never felt comfortable in Hawaii
— where he had moved to shoot the series — a fact
not helped by his arrest by local police
landed him in jail. Cuse told USA Today,
"Hawaii was not his bag. Real
life intervened and forced us to
end the arc of that character much
sooner than we would have liked."
In 2010, Akinnuoye-Agbaje was said to have been
offered a cameo in the series' epic finale,
where he would have returned as the
faithful Mr. Eko. But according to
E! Online, he turned it down —
reportedly due to a pay dispute,
as the actor was said to have been
looking for far more than he was offered.
"I am not sorry for this. I am proud of this."
The first "Star Wars" series on Disney+, "The
Mandalorian," stars Pedro Pascal behind that
iconic mask. There's plenty of familiar
faces in the supporting cast as well,
including former MMA fighter Gina Carano. But not
long after the show's second season concluded,
it was announced that Carano was
out, and it was no secret as to why.
According to THR, rumors that Disney was looking
to axe the actress began circulating after she
made a series of controversial social media
posts regarding multiple polarizing topics.
From comments on the Covid vaccines to voter fraud
in the 2020 United States Presidential election,
Carano did not keep her thoughts to herself. The
final straw was her anti-Semitic post in which she
compared the experience of conservatives to the
suffering of Jewish people during the Holocaust.
In response to growing calls for her
dismissal among the public — led by
the hashtag #FireGinaCarano — Disney was
forced to issue a statement. The company
said that she wasn't under contract, that
she wouldn't be continuing in the series,
and that they condemn her online
comments. The release read,
"Her social media posts denigrating
people based on their cultural
and religious identities are
abhorrent and unacceptable."
Willa Holland was a child actress who grew up
amid the hustle and bustle of Hollywood thanks
to her family roots, since her ex-stepfather is
"Scarface" director Brian De Palma. In the 2000s,
she starred in two of the hottest teen
dramas, "The O.C." and "Gossip Girl,"
before graduating to superheroics in The CW's
"Arrow." There she starred as Oliver Queen's
upstart younger sister Thea, who eventually
trains to become a vigilante herself. She
ultimately takes on the super-identity of
Speedy and becomes Green Arrow's partner.
Starring for six seasons in the hit
series, Holland was a stalwart of the
main cast and an integral part of Arrow's
universe. But in the middle of Season 6,
audiences were left stunned when Speedy set
off on her own mission with boyfriend Roy
Harper — the hero known as Arsenal. This wasn't
just a creative way for the writers to shake up
the status quo in the lead-up to the final two
seasons, but an exit orchestrated by Holland
herself. Producer and series co-creator
Marc Guggenheim told Entertainment Weekly,
"Season 6 is the end of her contract.
Going into season 6, with all of us
knowing it was the end of her contract,
Willa expressed the desire to move on."
"Find the best version of myself, whoever she is."
The decision was made to
not kill off the character,
though, as producers had a fondness for
both Speedy and Holland. Sure enough,
Holland returned for a handful of guest
appearances over the final seasons.
For three seasons, Matt Smith took on
the role of the Doctor in Doctor Who.
Head writer and executive producer
Steven Moffat was very impressed by
Smith from the beginning — after seeing him act,
he knew that Smith was the perfect choice
to play the eleventh Doctor. But ultimately,
Smith became too burned out by the demands
of the role. He told The Hollywood Reporter —
"I'd always talked about leaving after the 50th
anniversary. It's a very intense process to play
the Doctor. The line-learning is really hard, and
you have to live away from home for nine or 10
months a year. I love the show, and it wasn't an
easy choice to come to, but it's the right time."
"So, what now, doctor?"
"Well. Time to get cracking,
doctor."
"Mhmm."
However, it seems that Smith now has mixed
feelings about his eventual decision to leave,
as he has stated that he wished he could have
spent more time working with his
talented co-star Jenna Coleman.
Debuting in 1993, Terry Farrell portrayed Jadzia
Dax in "Star Trek: Deep Space Nine," before the
character was killed off in the Season 6 finale to
the dismay of many. She'd been a stalwart series
regular, was married to a fellow main character,
and was best friend to the show's captain.
While fans may have been blindsided,
Farrell has been more than open about
her exit from the series over the
years. In a 2011 chat with TrekMovie,
Farrell said she was feeling some burnout
after a six-year run. She explained,
"I was just really tired. I was tired of waking up
at four in the morning. I was
tired of all the minutiae."
At the same time, her contract was up, and
she was receiving interest elsewhere around
Hollywood. She decided to renegotiate for
less screen time: as she told Trek Today —
"I did suggest in the wake of that I could
be recurring [...] not be in every episode."
Instead, her Trill symbiont got a
new body in the form of Nicole De
Boer. In the 2018 documentary, "What We
Left Behind," Farrell was more candid,
describing how she had felt
disrespected by producers. She said,
"The last season when I was told by one of the
producers that I was really lucky to be there,
and I really should sign the next contract
because if I weren't there on the set,
I'd be at K-Mart. That was the last straw for me."
Farrell eventually landed a lead role
in the NBC series "Becker" in 1998.
In the late '90s, actor Jerry O'Connell
starred in "Sliders," a cult favorite
that's better than you probably
remember. But after its third season,
the show moved from Fox to the Sci-Fi Channel —
and in a 1998 interview in the Chicago Tribune,
the actor expressed excitement
about the new direction, saying,
"It's great to be on the Sci-Fi Channel because
we can cater to a more intelligent audience."
But as O'Connell recalled in a 2016 interview
with Yahoo, things didn't turn out the way he'd
hoped. Instead of the show using effects
to explore parallel worlds in unique ways,
O'Connell thought "Sliders" had become too
focused on action and fighting. His displeasure
with the show's altered tone coincided with the
expiration of his contract — and as a result,
the actor felt that it was the
right time to step away, explaining,
"I had learned all that I was going to learn
from the show after four seasons, and I decided
to leave when my contract was up. I was hoping
that they would go on with my brother, who joined
the cast in Season 4. They got pretty mad and
decided to reboot the whole thing and blow it up."
"I don't know if I'm ready for all that."
Audiences seem to love live-action adaptations
of popular young adult sci-fi novel series,
and "The 100" is one of the biggest on the
small screen. Running for seven seasons,
it launched on The CW in 2014 and centered on
a group of people who come back to Earth almost
a hundred years after leaving in the wake
of nuclear armageddon. Despite its sprawling
ensemble cast, only three actors starred
in all seven seasons. Ricky Whittle though
could have made it four, were it not for his
leaving the show inexplicably after the during
the third season. His character ended up
being killed off in an eye-popping twist.
The real revelation came in
the aftermath of his departure,
when Whittle revealed behind-the-scenes
turmoil in an interview with Afterbuzz
TV. He explained that it was his choice
to leave the show, and claimed that there
was serious beef between him and the series
showrunner Jason Rothenberg. Whittle said,
"He was professionally bullying me, cutting
out all the storyline that I was supposed to
be doing. Cutting lines, cutting everything
out, trying to make my character and myself
as insignificant as possible to the point
where it was starting to get me down."
To get across just how bad things
were between them, Whittle added,
"If this was in the playground, it would have
got physical [...] but I'm an adult and
violence isn't going to solve anything."
After joining the long-running British sci-fi
smash "Doctor Who" in the titular role,
Christopher Eccleston found the famous
part to be more trouble than it was
worth. He ended up leaving the show after
only one season, leaving fans wondering
why. Eccleston explained during a panel
discussion at New York Comic-Con in 2019,
"I left only because of those three individuals
and the way they were running the show. I loved
playing the character. I felt I was going
to play the Doctor my way and I wasn't
going to get involved with those politics
and that wasn't workable, so off I went."
Eccleston eventually admitted that the
"three individuals" he had professional
conflicts with were the showrunner, producer,
and co-producer of the show. He also faced
other obstacles while playing the Doctor: he
struggled with an eating disorder while filming,
and felt he was treated unfairly by
the media. Eventually, he reached a
point where he felt that staying in the
role was no longer in his best interests.
Before joining the cast of "Star Trek:
The Next Generation" as Wesley Crusher,
Wil Wheaton had already made a name for
himself with roles in films like "Stand
By Me." Playing Crusher represented a career
boost for Wheaton — but after a few seasons,
he decided to leave to pursue other
aspirations in Hollywood. Wheaton
explained during a panel discussion at the
Calgary Comic and Entertainment Expo in 2012,
"Initially I thought it was a really
smart business career move. In some
ways it was and in more ways it
wasn't. What I wasn't prepared
for was how much I was going to
miss the people on this stage."
He admitted that he didn't make much of an effort
to stay in touch with the rest of
the cast after making his exit,
and eventually, he felt embarrassed about
his decision to leave the show. He added,
"I just felt really ashamed of myself. I
felt like I just couldn't go to the set — I
felt like I couldn't look them in the eye and
that I couldn't invite them to my wedding."
Fortunately, years later, he was able to
reconnect with his former co-stars — and
unsurprisingly, they had no hard feelings
towards him for leaving the show.
On the military science fiction series
"Stargate SG-1," Don S. Davis played
George Hammond, who runs the military
base Stargate Command. Hammond is a stern,
straight-laced guy who genuinely cares
about the people under his watch,
his characterization possibly inspired by
Davis' own experiences in the military.
Davis eventually admitted that he had to leave
Stargate earlier than he had intended. Why did
he have to quit? He was dealing with multiple
health problems that made it very difficult for
him to continue acting. Davis stated that the
showrunners were always willing to work around
his surgeries, doctor's appointments, and
other scheduling conflicts — but eventually,
he simply couldn't keep pushing ahead with work.
Davis explained in an interview with GateWorld,
"'Stargate' stood by me. They made sure
that there was nothing that I was asked
to do that might put me in harm's way. But
there comes a time where you really can't,
if you're in my condition. I'm
a heart patient. I'm a diabetic.
I've got other minor problems, and
it's really time to slow down."
Sadly, Davis passed away after
suffering a heart attack in 2008.
"Star Trek" is one of the most well-known
sci-fi franchises of all time, but not
every actor involved is satisfied with
their character's arc. Denise Crosby,
who played Security Chief Tasha Yar
in "Star Trek: The Next Generation,"
didn't think that the writers gave her
enough interesting material to work with.
Over time, Crosby became more and more
frustrated with the way Tasha Yar was
portrayed, as she started to feel like more of
a prop than an actress. She has stated that,
out of all the characters she has played,
Tasha was the one she held nearest to her
heart — but eventually, she realized
that she would never be able to develop
the character further. Crosby explained
in a 1996 interview with StarTrek.com,
"I wanted to leave as I was struggling
with not being able to do much with the
character. I had all these ideas and couldn't
do them. I was just stage dressing. I chose to
leave instead of just being satisfied with
that. I've never regretted my decision."
"I'm not supposed to be here, sir."
The superhero sci-fi show "Misfits" was
an unexpected hit in the United Kingdom,
and helped to launch the careers of several
rising stars, including Robert Sheehan. In
"Misfits," Sheehan starred as Nathan Young, a
man who realizes that he is immortal when he
wakes up in his own coffin. But after an exciting
character arc, Sheehan decided to quit while he
was ahead and take his career in a new direction
after two seasons. Sheehan told Digital Spy,
"I was absolutely quite happy about when I went
off, it seemed like a no-brainer at the time,
because I was just a restless fella
who was trying to go off and do as
much different stuff as possible. I'd
done two good summers with that show,
so [it] was wildly impatient to do other stuff."
It turned out to be a good career move, proving
that "Misfits" opened up doors for him. After
his departure, Sheehan landed a regular role
as Darren on "Love/Hate," and more recently,
the role of fan-favorite Klaus
Hargreeves on "The Umbrella Academy."
Corin Nemec ended up landing a part on "Stargate
SG-1" in an unexpected way. Michael Shanks,
who had played Daniel Jackson, left the
show after season five, and the writers
didn't want to leave a void in the SG-1 team.
Nemec happened to be auditioning for another
role when he bumped into the casting team for
"Stargate SG-1." They thought he seemed like
the perfect fit to play Jonas Quinn, a new
character they would be adding to the show.
Nemec loved working on "Stargate," and even got
to pitch ideas for different episodes. Eventually,
Shanks was able to come back for another season.
Nemec hoped to stay on board too — but the writers
decided it was time for Jonas Quinn to go.
When asked why he was written off the show,
Nemec admitted that he didn't know why the
writers couldn't have simply incorporated
both his character and Michael
Shanks' into the storyline. However,
he suspected that budget limitations may
have been a major factor in the decision.
When "Star Trek: Voyager" first launched,
it featured several new alien characters
whose presence helped set the show apart from
previous spin-offs. This included the duo of
quirky cook Neelix and the child-like Ocompan
Kes, the latter of whom was played by actress
Jennifer Lien. In Season 4, a new cast member
joined — the fan-favorite former Borg drone
Seven of Nine, played by Jeri Ryan — and it's
no coincidence that her arrival coincided with
Lien's departure. Series producer Jeri
Taylor said in a DVD special feature,
"The studio felt that we had too many characters."
Because Seven of Nine was
going to join the regular cast,
someone had to go. Lien drew the short
straw, though it wasn't entirely a
random choice: Brannon Braga told
an audience at the 2014 VegasCon,
"To my recollection it was a creative
decision, and it was a failure of
imagination on the writers' part. We were
running out of things to do with Kes."
Still, the series didn't say goodbye forever, as
Kes returned for the Season 6 episode "Fury." That
episode helped wrap up the long-running story
of the character's abbreviated life cycle,
and gave her a more fitting send-off
than she'd seen in Season 4's "The Gift."
There are two generations of Richard Dean
Anderson fans. The first know him for his role
as the crafty do-gooder MacGyver, whose titular
series made him an '80s icon. But there's another
generation of fans who know him best for his role
as Jack O'Neill in "Stargate SG-1." Anderson had
taken over the role from action icon Kurt
Russell, who'd starred in the film the show
had been adapted from — but he found a way to
make it his own. Unfortunately, following the
show's eighth season, Anderson departed, and
it was never the same. So why did he leave?
Apparently, it all came down to priorities.
In 1998, Anderson and his partner April A.
Prose had a child, and by 2004, Anderson
was feeling the pull of family. In 2018,
Gateworld.com covered his appearance at Fan Expo
Canada, where they discussed his exit from the
show, citing his desire to spend more time with
his wife and daughter. More than a decade after
leaving the series, though, Anderson said
he would have no problems with the notion
of returning to the role — with concrete
limitations. He told fans at the event,
"As far as punching the clock and going to work
I wouldn't mind doing a mini-series of some kind.
Something that had a clear beginning and end.
[...] I would do something along those lines."
In 2021, a new version of Superman hit the small
screen with "Superman & Lois," an action-adventure
series that sees the famous comic book couple
raising a pair of teenagers. Jordan Elsass and
Alex Garfin play Clark Kent's sons, Jonathan and
Jordan. Following the first two seasons, however,
Elsass made a surprise announcement
that he would be leaving the series,
and a report in Deadline mentioned sources
claiming that Elsass was dealing with
personal issues. The actor sat down with The
Wrap about a week later to clear the air,
revealing a struggle with
his mental health. He said,
"It's sad, it's a real shame. I know
that I was pumped for Season 3, for sure,
but what are you going to do? Anyway, mental
health is definitely 100-percent priority.
It's pinnacle. It's got to take precedence.
And mine has been [...] it's been rough."
Though Elsass didn't go any
further into his experience,
it sounds like he may step away from
Hollywood altogether. He elaborated,
"I need some time to myself. I'm still debating
whether I'm even going to act for a while."
Sadly, "Star Trek" is still losing stars to this
day, with "Star Trek: Discovery" abandoning actor
Shazad Latif after just two seasons. While his
co-stars Jason Isaacs and Michelle Yeoh were
never intended to last very long, Latif's
situation was something a bit different.
In the first season, Latif starred as Lieutenant
Ash Tyler, while his dual role as the mysterious
Klingon Voq was kept a tightly guarded secret —
after all, it sat at the center of the season's
major plot twist. But he returned in Season 2
as Tyler, who'd abandoned his Klingon identity
and began a romantic relationship with
series lead Michael Burnham. But the
character said a surprising goodbye in the
Season 2 finale, leaving to head up the covert
intelligence agency known as Section 31. This
isn't a case of Latif requesting off of the series
though — quite the opposite in fact. In a 2022
interview, the actor revealed just what happened.
According to a report from TrekMovie, producers
had been planning a spin-off series focused on
Section 31 to star Latif alongside superstar
Michelle Yeoh. But because of Yeoh's limited
availability, the series has yet to get
off the ground, leaving Latif in limbo.
"You understand what I'm saying?"
Aml Ameen played Capheus on the first season of
"Sense8," but fans were thus surprised when they
found out that the same character would be
played by actor Toby Onwumere in the second.
It seems that Ameen's departure was a result
of some kind of behind-the-scenes conflict with
executive producer and director Lana Wachowski
— apparently, the two began clashing during
table reads for season two in Berlin. Rather
than working out their differences before the
cameras began rolling, Ameen and Wachowski
continued to butt heads when filming for
new episodes began in India. As a result,
Ameen was abruptly replaced by a new actor.
It's a mystery as to what actually caused
the tensions between Ameen and Wachowski.
Perhaps it was merely creative differences
and disagreements about the storyline for
Ameen's character in season two. Maybe Ameen and
Wachowski didn't get along on a personal level,
and their strained relationship was
beginning to affect the atmosphere
on set. Whatever the reason, fans
may never get a straight answer.
Paul Campbell played Billy Keikeya on the 2004
series "Battlestar Galactica." For two years,
his character served as the personal assistant to
President Laura Roslin. But Campbell did not sign
an official contract with the show, and while
he was working on "Battlestar Galactica," he
was still open to new opportunities. At the
beginning of season two, he landed a role in
a new pilot which took him away from filming for
a few episodes. When said pilot didn't work out,
he returned to "Battlestar Galactica" — but
his appearances on the show became sporadic,
and the showrunners were getting frustrated with
his absences. This resulted in his character
being killed off. Campbell explained in
a 2006 interview with The Scifi World,
"So after that [they] kind of gave me the
ultimatum and said, 'Sign a contract for
five years, or we kind of need to go our separate
ways.' And I kind of put it off and put it off,
then eventually they just said, 'Look, we can
tell you're not really committed to the show,
and we can't write story lines. So
we've decided to kill the character.'"